CLAIMING THAT UKRAINE'S
CONNECTION TO THE WEST IS,
QUOTE, A DEADLY FOR RUSSIA AND
SUICIDAL FOR UKRAINE.
HOW DO THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY GET BY WITHOUT RELIABLE
ACCESS TO WATER, HEAT, OR POWER?
AND KNOWING THAT WINTER IS
COMING?
I MET WITH RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES IN THE CAPITAL TO
SEE HOW THEY ARE ADAPTING TO
THE ONGOING BLACKOUTS.
>> WEEK FOUR OF UKRAINE'S NEW
STRUGGLE AGAINST A COLD AND
DARK.
ROLLING BLACKOUTS BLANKET KYIV,
NIGHTTIME IS SPOOKY, AND
ENTERING IN THIS HIGH RISE
APARTMENT COMPLEX TO SEE HOW
RESIDENTS ARE COPING WITH
RUSSIA'S CONSTANT ATTACKS ON
KEY INSTRUCTOR.
UP TO THE 12TH FLOOR, NO LIGHT
IN THE STAIRWELL.
BUT OUR CAMERAS AND NO
ELEVATOR.
JULIA MANDEL JOINS US HOBBLING
DOWN ON CRUTCHES, THE FOOT SHE
FRACTURED BY TRIPPING OVER THE
STEP THE FIRST NIGHT OF THE
BLACKOUTS.
SHE'S A JOURNALIST AND A FORMER
PRESS SECRETARY TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY.
TOGETHER, WE VISIT HER NEIGHBOR
NATALIYA WITH AN 18 MONTH OLD
DAUGHTER, JUST ONE OF A WHOLE
GENERATION OF A TRAUMATIZED
KYIV KIDS, ESPECIALLY THE
CONSTANT ARID SIRENS.
WHAT IS SHE STRESSED?
>> SHE IS LIKE, OH, OH.
SHE'S POINTING TO THE WINDOW SO
THAT SHE KNOWS SOMETHING GOES
WRONG.
>> THE TWO OF THEM ARE
RECOVERING FROM A TWO HOUR
ORDEAL TRAPPED IN THEIR TINY
ELEVATOR WHEN THE POWER WENT
OUT.
NOW, ALL OVER KYIV, RESIDENTS,
INCLUDING SMALL CARE BOXES
INSIDE WITH WATER, SNACKS, AND
ANTI-ANXIETY MEDICINES.
BY THE TIME WE SAT DOWN TO TALK,
THE POWER POPPED BACK ON AGAIN
AFTER NINE HOURS ON THIS DAY.
DO YOU FEEL DEMORALIZED?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE, ENOUGH
ALREADY.
IT'S TIME TO SURRENDER AND
NEGOTIATE?
>> NO WAY.
LOOK, WE HAVE PASSED THROUGH
THE HARDSHIPS OF THE 90S.
WE DIDN'T HAVE LIGHT, WATER,
HEATING, AND EVERYTHING FOR
HOURS AND HOURS EVERY DAY.
THAT THEN WAS DESPERATE BECAUSE
WE KNEW IT WAS ABOUT POVERTY.
NOW IT'S ABOUT WAR.
WE KNOW THAT WE MUST WIN.
>> WINNING THIS PHASE OF THE
WAR COMES WITH WEAPONS LIKE
THESE TO CHARGE PHONES AND ANY
OTHER EMERGENCY EQUIPMENT.
>> IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING HERE IN UKRAINE.
THE POWER BANK.
WITHOUT IT, WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONNECTION.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT NOW TO
KNOW YOUR RELATIVES ARE OKAY.
>> THEY TELL US GENERATORS ARE
ALMOST ALL SOLD OUT AND SUPER
EXPENSIVE NOW, AS WELL AS
CANDLES, TORCHES, AND HEADLAMPS.
NATALIA HAS IMPROVISED LIGHT
FROM A WATER BOTTLE AND HER
IPHONE.
DOWNTOWN, IT'S DIRE FOR
BUSINESSES AS WELL.
EVERY BEAUTY SALON OPERATES ON
HAIRDRYER'S FOR THAT BLOWOUT
AND WATER TO WASH OUT SHAMPOO
AND THE DYE.
ELENA IS TAKING HER CHANCES
TODAY.
>> [INTERPRETER]
AFTER WE FINISHED DYEING IT, I
MIGHT HAVE TO GO HOME THE DRY
IT.
BUT IT IS FINE.
>> JUST ONE FLOOR HERE HAS
POWER.
THE OTHERS ARE DARK.
BEFORE THE WAR, HAIR HOUSE HAD
150 CLIENTS A DAY.
NOW IT'S MORE LIKE 50.
THE SALON HAS LOST 60% OF ITS
REVENUE.
AS DIMITRI, THE COMMERCIAL
MANAGER, TELLS ME, THEY KEEP
CALM AND CARRY ON.
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
WORK EVEN WITH NO LIGHT,
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY, WE SHOULD
HELP OUR PEOPLE.
WE WILL DO OUR JOB UNTIL THE
END.
WE BELIEVE THAT SOONER OR LATER
THE LIGHTS WILL COME.
>> LIKE SO MANY CIVILIANS, AND
THEY SAY, INJURING THESE
HARDSHIPS ON THE HOME FRONT IS
PART OF THEIR WAR EFFORT,
SUPPORTING THEIR TROOPS ON THE
FRONT LINES WHO ARE FIGHTING TO
KEEP UKRAINE INDEPENDENT,
FIGHTING FOR THEIR HOMELAND.
NOW, AS YOU AND RESIDENT
COORDINATOR HERE IN UKRAINE,
DENISE BROWN OVERSEES THE
GLOBAL RESPONSE TO THE ACUTE
HUMANITARIAN NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE HERE.
SHE IS MET WITH UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS ABOUT PROVIDING
GENERATORS, MOBILE BOILER
HOUSES, AND OTHER EQUIPMENT TO
FIX THEIR ATTACKED ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WILL IT BE ENOUGH?
LET ME ASK HER.
DENISE BROWN, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
WE JUST HEARD FROM CITIZENS OF
THIS CITY.
WE HEARD THE MAYOR TODAY SAY
THAT NEARLY HALF 1 MILLION
PEOPLE WERE INTERRUPTED IN
TERMS OF ENERGY REQUIREMENTS.
HOW TOUGH IS THIS FOR YOU AND
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO
MITIGATE?
>> IT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
COMMUNITIES ON THE FRONT LINE,
THAT'S WHERE THE GOVERNMENT HAS
ASKED US TO FOCUS ATTENTION.
WE HAVE BIG TEAMS IN THE UNITED
NATIONS, NATIONAL PARTNERS,
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS BASED
ALL ALONG AND THESE AREAS, THE
FRONT LINES.
WE ARE FOCUSING ON THEM.
BUT NOW, WITH THE ENERGY CRISIS,
WE MET YESTERDAY WITH THE PRIME
MINISTER WHO ASKED WHAT MORE WE
COULD ALL BE DOING.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO MORE.
WE NEED TO PREVENT A
HUMANITARIAN CATASTROPHE OVER
THE WINTER MONTHS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> YOU'VE SEEN, BECAUSE HE
LIVED HERE, WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE CAPITAL, KYIV.
IT'S PROBABLY BETTER OFF THAN
THE PLACES YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT ALONG THE FRONT LINES.
HOW DIRE IS THE HUMANITARIAN
SITUATION IN PLACES WHERE HOMES
ARE OBLITERATED, WHERE THE
ENERGY IS OFF THERE, SPORADIC
WATER?
>> I'VE SEEN A LOT OF THINGS IN
MY TIME.
THE FEMININE SOMALIA, THE
EARTHQUAKE IN HAITI.
IT'S ALMOST OVERWHELMING WHEN
WE STAND IN FRONT OF THESE
BUILDINGS, PEOPLES HOMES THAT
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BY THE
MISSILE STRIKES OR SCHOOLS
WHICH HAVE BEEN DESTROYED IN
THE ATTACKS OR HOSPITALS WHERE
WOMEN SHOULD BE GIVING BIRTH
DESTROYED BY ATTACKS.
--
PEOPLE HAVE HAD TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES.
PEOPLE LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
WE ARE OPERATING IN A CONTEXT
OF WAR.
OUR TEAMS SEE EVERY DAY THE
REMNANTS OF WAR, THE BODIES ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD, AS WE
DELIVER TO LOCATIONS CLOSE TO
THE FRONT LINES.
THE THREAT OF MISSILE STRIKES,
WE LIVE WITH THAT AS WELL.
>> IS THAT VERY DIFFICULT IN
TERMS OF EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND EVEN YOU AND YOUR
TEAM'S?
>> OF COURSE.
WE ARE WITH THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
I HAVE MY APARTMENT HERE.
WE ARE LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
WE ARE NOT IN A PROTECTED
COMPOUNDS.
OUR STOMACHS TURN IN KNOTS WHEN
WE HEAR SIRENS GOING OFF AS
WELL.
>> TALKING ABOUT SCHOOLS, WE
HAVE PICTURES WE PUT OUT OF YOU
VISITING ONE OF THESE, IF YOU
CAN TELL US WHERE.
YOU ARE DOING SOME ART THERAPY
WITH KIDS THERE.
WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND?
I SAW THIS CHILD IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING, 18 MONTHS.
SHE'S TRAUMATIZED, ACCORDING TO
HER MOTHER.
YOU KNOW?
EVERY TIME THERE'S A BANG OR
SIREN, THE CHILD GETS STRESSED
OUT.
SHE'S 18 MONTHS OLD.
>> THE MAYOR TOLD ME A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, 33 DAYS OF SILENCE.
33 DAYS OF SILENCE THERE SINCE
THE START OF THE WAR.
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO THE CHILD
WHO SEES THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND THEN THE AIR STRIKE THAT
FOLLOWS?
THESE MECHANISMS PUT IN PLACE
WITH AUTHORITIES, UNICEF, AND
OTHERS, IT'S TO TRY TO HELP
CHILDREN IN THE IMMEDIATE TERM.
THIS IS A LONG TERM TRAUMA.
THIS IS THE NEXT FIGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE NUMBER OF
REFUGEES.
I THINK IT IS SOMETHING LIKE A
THIRD OF THE POPULATION IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS EITHER BEEN FORCED
OR FLED FROM THEIR HOMES.
WE HEAR THE GOVERNMENT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS, SINCE THE
ENERGY ATTACK, SAYING, LISTEN,
DO NOT COME HOME.
THE WINTER IS GOING TO BE TOO
HARD FOR YOU AND US TO MANAGE.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE, MORE PEOPLE WILL
FLEE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY WILL DO?
>> THIS IS WHY RESPONDING TO
THIS ENERGY CRISIS NOW IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
PEOPLE HOME, TO KEEP THEM WARM,
KEEP THEM SAFE AND GIVE THEM AN
ALTERNATIVE TO MOVING.
BECAUSE MOVING WHERE?
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IN WHAT WE CALL
COLLECTIVE CENTERS, WHICH ARE
BASICALLY SCHOOLS, UNIVERSITIES,
ORPHANAGES, WHICH WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNMENT TO
WINTER EYES, BASICALLY BOILERS
AND WINDOWS.
>> WHERE DO YOU GET THIS STUFF?
EVEN HERE, PEOPLE ARE SAYING
GENERATORS ARE PRACTICALLY
UNAVAILABLE.
IF THEY ARE, THEY ARE GOING FOR
A PREMIUM.
--
WHERE DO YOU GET ALL THE STUFF?
>> WE STARTED PREPARING FOR
THIS BACK IN JULY.
THE WINTER IS PREDICTABLE.
WE BROUGHT IN THE SUMMER.
NOW, WITH THE ADDITIONAL NEEDS,
IT'S NO LONGER POSSIBLE TO BUY
HERE.
WE WILL HAVE TO GO OUTSIDE.
THIS IS GOING TO REQUIRE A
COORDINATED INTERNATIONAL
EFFORT TO PREVENT THIS
DETERIORATING FURTHER FOR THE
POPULATION.
>> SO WE HEARD TODAY, THE NEWS
WAS THAT G7 COUNTRIES HAVE
TALKED NOT JUST ABOUT MILITARY
AND --
ASSISTANCE, BUT THIS KIND OF
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY WILL HAVE
TO HELP YOU ALL, HELP THE
GOVERNMENT HERE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
IF YOU ARE THE COORDINATOR AND
A COUNTRY OR THE G7 HAS PLEDGED
HELP, WHAT DO YOU DO WITH IT?
ALL >> WE'VE AGREED WITH THE
PRIME MINISTER TO PUT FORWARD A
PLATFORM COORDINATION FOR THE
ENERGY CRISIS.
THERE ARE HUGE NEEDS.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO IS BUYING
WHAT, WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO,
WHO IS HANDLING.
WE WILL FACILITATE, ASSIST THEM
WITH THAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN CHARGE
OF THIS PART OF THE CRISIS.
IT IS MASSIVE AND COULD BE
NATIONWIDE.
>> THE AREAS APPARENTLY
ACCESSED, OBVIOUSLY, THE AREAS
UNDER RUSSIAN OCCUPATION --
CAN YOU GO ANYWHERE WHERE THE
UKRAINIANS ARE BASICALLY IN
CHARGE OR DO YOU HAVE
RESTRICTIONS?
>> THERE ARE NO RESTRICTIONS
FOR US IN UKRAINE.
FOR THE NEWLY RETAKEN AREAS, WE
WAIT TELL THE MILITARY TELLS US
THEY'VE DONE HUMANITARIAN DE
MINING AND THEN WE CAN MOVE.
IN THAT NORMALLY TAKES A COUPLE
DAYS.
IT'S VERY TRUE THAT IN TERMS OF
CROSS LINE, WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
RELIABLY OR REGULARLY DELIVER
FOR THE MOMENT.
>> WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE PEOPLE?
>> THAT'S THE QUESTION, ISN'T
IT?
THAT'S THE QUESTION I ASK.
WE ARE IMPARTIAL, WE ARE
NEUTRAL.
AS UNITED NATIONS, I'M SUPPOSED
TO BE ASSISTING UKRAINIANS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY ARE.
I REGULARLY ASK TO CROSS THAT
FRONT LINE.
FOR THE MOMENT, I HAVEN'T GOT
THE GUARANTEE OF SECURITY THAT
I NEED TO SEND MY TEAM ACROSS.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL GET
IT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE STATE
OF HUMANITARIAN SECURITY IS FOR
UKRAINIANS IN OCCUPIED AREAS?
>> I ASSUME IT'S THE SAME.
AS FOR THE UKRAINIANS